well as did tsipras actually win
anything at all from herckel good
morning well he got that military honor
roll he got good will and mr. tsipras
has a better relationship with Madame
Merkel which in some ways was the point
of the talks but both sides that were
very clear that they weren't really
gonna do a whole lot in terms of
directly addressing the crisis mr.
tsipras said that he wasn't in Berlin to
beg quote beg for money both sides
really at that press conference tripping
over each other trying to make nice and
mr. tsipras said that both sides in the
popular press as well should avoid
stereotyping inna that Bailey this
neither are the Greeks lazy nor are the
Germans responsible for the maladies and
drawbacks in Greece as I said earlier
and we have to work hard to break these
terrible stereotypes on both sides mr.
tsipras also said that look in terms of
the liquidity crisis that they weren't
going to have anything concrete there he
also said all of Greece's problems
aren't external they are themselves to
blame now mrs. Merkel she said she
couldn't solve those liquidity issues
that's for all 19 members or 18 if you
exclude groups of the Eurogroup and guys
if there is any tension there it was
over this issue of war world war two
reparations mr. tsipras raised it he
said as a moral issue an ethical issue
mrs. Merkel said that it was really a
case closed from their perspective and
both sides really tried to separate the
reparations issue from the debt talks
and mrs. Merkel suggested the
possibility of a separate almost
humanitarian fund for Greece no idea on
how or no indication of how big that
will be overall a lot on style a lot of
niceties but very little on substance
and what the euro zone's going to do to
help Greece prevent a liquidity crisis
as early as next week guys and Hans I
mean talking of tensions Mario Draghi
weighed in on Greece's liquidity
problems from Brussels and many accusing
ECB of blackmailing I mean is he a
sympathetic central banker right now and
you know no Mario Draghi is a frustrated
central banker this came out in
testimony in front of the European
Parliament yesterday he was asked this
very
question are you blackmailing Greece and
here was his response first of all are
we blackmailing Greece well it's a bit
rich when you look at the exposure that
we have with Greece ECB has 104 billion
of exposure to Greece this is equal to
sixty-five percent or Greek GDP and it's
the highest exposure in the eurozone so
it's a what sort of blackmail is this
it's up to you to judge Caroline you
take these comments from Draghi
yesterday and then you add them to what
he was saying behind closed doors late
Thursday night expressing frustration
with the Greeks that they weren't giving
their technocrats access to all the
relevant ministries in in Athens you see
it seems like the ECB is not in a
forgiving mood not a negotiating move
and that's important when we look at ela
which will be reconsidered this week the
emergency liquidity assistance whether
or not to raise that ceiling the ecv has
as much say about liquidity in some ways
as the Eurogroup guys